mary wants the fraction of pink blocks
in model b to be equivalent to the
fraction of pink blocks in model a how
many blocks in model b need to be pink
in order to make that happen so let's
look at model a so how many equal
sections are there's one two three four
five equal sections
there are five equal sections and what
fraction of them are pink
well you have one of them is pink one of
the one of the blocks is pink so
one-fifths of one-fifth of the blocks
over here in model a is pink now we have
to think about how to make one-fifth
pink right over here so let's think
about it so how many first of all total
blocks are there there's one two three
let me actually just another color one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20.
there are 20
there are 20 total blocks here and you
see that this is the exact same length
model b is the exact same length as
model a
and so for every block that you have in
model a for every block here in or you
must have four in model b because we
went from 5 sections to 20. so we're
essentially multiplying by 4. you even
see it here if we were to just draw a
line right down here you see
that for every block in model a you have
one two three four blocks in model b
so one block in model a that is
pink would be the same thing as four
blocks in model b we would literally
just multiply this times four
so four of the 20 will need to be made
pink so 1
4. and you see that it exactly matches
up this is the exact same fraction of
the entire of the entire model over here
so when they say how many blocks in
model b need to be pink to make that
happen it would be four